[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 loisirs comme chaque jeudi
l'essentiel des informations pour passer
un bon week-end dans les yvelines et
tout de suite le sommaire de cette
semaine un zeste de sport une pincée de
fêtes et une bonne dose de caritatif
l'association sportive handball de saint
cyr fontenay organise ce week-end son
tournoi de noël solidarité aussi à la
commanderie pour le deuxième week-end de
son noël décaler le site saint
quentinois invite associations et
créateurs à vous faire découvrir leur
univers et l'agenda complet de vos
sorties au programme du sport du cinéma
est un spectacle on débute nos rendez
vous avec un peu de culture les 13 et 14
décembre prochain le théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines reçoit pour la
première fois josette baïz l'aco et gras
la chorégraphe marseillaise propose
d'est en ouest avec son groupe grenade
la particularité sur celle des enfants
un mot du directeur du théâtre avant un
extrait juste avant les fêtes de noël
nous aurons la grande chance
d'accueillir une chorégraphe qui
s'appelle joseph by chorégraphe qui n'a
jamais été accueillie au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et pourtant ça
allait bien
trente ans maintenant quelle oeuvre dans
les quartiers nord de marseille
son travail consiste tout simplement à
accueillir des enfants à partir de l'âge
de 8 ans 9 ans à les former et à les
garder jusqu'à l'âge de 20 ans avec ses
enfants il travaille sur les
chorégraphies de grand soin des peaux
exotiques et les crues soit des
chorégraphies qu'elles commandent à de
grands chorégraphes à travers le monde
soit des chorégraphies qui existent et
qui sont emblématiques de la danse
d'aujourd'hui
le spectacle s'appelle d'est en ouest
parce qu'on parcourt le monde à travers
la danse contemporaine jeu ce sera juste
avant les fêtes de noël d'est en ouest
c'est le groupe grenade et c'est la
chorégraphe josette baïz
[Musique]
toutes et tous
et
[Musique]
du sport à présent ils vont jouer pour
la bonne cause à sociales l'école cinq
équipes vont s'affronter dans un tournoi
de handball avec nous pour en parler
les deux créneaux bonjour bonjour vous
êtes responsable de la section loisirs
de l'association
c'est déjà la neuvième édition du
tournoi absolument absolument c'est la
neuvième dimanche prochain de 10h à 18h
à saint cyr et on est très heureux de
l'organiser et très heureux et très
impatients de tous d'accueillir beaucoup
de joueurs d'où vient cette idée d'un
tournoi avec lui ni des solidaires en
fin d'année c'est parti d'un constat est
fait il ya neuf ans qu'il n'existait
rien qui illustrait vraiment cet esprit
un peu festif convivial qu'on peut qu'on
peut trouver dans le handball loisir qui
pour leur rappeler aux téléspectateurs
consiste sur un jeu mixte on joue en
mixte on n'a pas un enjeu de compétition
et que la montée des santons une
troisième mi-temps organisé par le club
recevant voilà c'est aussi pour le
plaisir de jouer cette année les fonds
vont être reversés à la fondation
abbé-pierre vous changer tous les ans
oui c'est un chien choix on a dès le
départ voulu placer faire se tourne au
profit d'une bonne cause
c'était les années précédentes au profit
développement du hand en fauteuil au
profit de sport sans frontières ont des
chiens guides d'aveuglés et cette année
c'est pour la fondation abbé pierre ou
alors il ya cinq équipes inscrites
weir a joué alors mantes la ville proche
vélizy proche d'ici montigny et le club
d'elancourt maurepas et on a le plaisir
cette année d'accueillir également
cormeilles en parisis qui vient du 95
sont toujours les mêmes équipes ou comme
les associations
ça change alors on essaye de changer on
essaye aussi d'inviter des équipes qui
sont dans cet esprit là qui ne viennent
kiffa qui viennent aussi pour vraiment
le plaisir de jouer et de se retrouver à
ce moment dans ces fêtes mais on
essayait aussi de changer pour
renouveler chaque année oui il ya une
particularité dans cet événement ça joue
mais de manière un peu spéciale zes est
déguisé absolument oui oui alors c'est
pas toujours très simple il faudrait il
faudra venir dimanche d'ailleurs voir
notre gardienne de but déguisé en clown
de lübeck ça je pense que ça vaudra son
pesant d'or effectivement et chaque
année on demande à chaque équipe de
choisir un thème de fin humide et
déguisements autour d'un thème donc
cette année ce sera les métiers par
exemple mais on a eu un super mario
l'année dernière on a eu vraiment des
choses très différentes et ça participe
voilà cet esprit cet esprit festif
convivial qu'on veut qu'on veut sous
lequel on veut placer ce tournoi vous
autorisez les entraînements aux costumes
pour s'y préparer ou c'est vraiment un
festival de gaillac le style sinon c'est
pas de préparation un échauffement on
reste sur du sport mais non et le but
c'est vraiment ça c'est de favoriser
alors c'est les métiers mais vous avez
choisi le btp oui absolument qu est-ce
qui vous plaisait dans ce thème fut le
délire le délire les casques de chantier
les salopettes alors on verra ce que ça
donnera
sur le jeu lui-même pas sûr qu'on soit
les meilleurs joueurs déguisés en
ouvriers du bâtiment mais voilà c'est
pas ça qui compte
ce qui compte c'est d'une part que le
tournoi soit réussie dans cet esprit
qu'on préserve cet esprit auquel on
tient beaucoup
et puis que voilà qu'on puisse aussi
apporté à collecter le plus possible de
fonds pour l'association c'est vraiment
ce qui nous tient à coeur
puis j'imagine 6 l'occasion de faire
découvrir vos activités pour ceux qui
seraient tentés absolument voici où
s'est ouvert c'est ouvert à tous
alors évidemment nos participants les
premiers sont quand même les équipes
leurs accompagnants les membres du club
mais le tournoi est vraiment ouvert à
tout le monde et j'invite j'invite
vraiment tous ceux qui seraient
intéressés à passer vous restez un bout
de la journée autant que vous voulez il
y aura une buvette des crêpes des
gaufres voilà à manger du sceau du froid
n'hésitez pas et justement pour ceux qui
ne jouaient pas qu'ils seraient pas sur
le terrain qu'ils voudraient soutenir
financièrement comment ça se passe alors
le on organise plusieurs animations dans
la journée une tombola donc acheté un
ticket de tombola
mais acheter une crêpe ça contribue
également puisque les recettes de la
buvette vent à l'association les enfants
des animations également d'un tournoi de
penalty le midi donc même un débutant
peut très bien s'inscrire encore une
fois le but n'est pas de gagner à tout
prix mais plutôt de participer merci de
crème ou alors on le rappelle le tournoi
de noël débutent à 10h le rendez vous
est pris au gymnase gérard philipe de
saint cyr l'école c'est ce dimanche 15
des sens si je peux remercier ces
derniers remerciements vraiment à tout
ce tout et tous les joueurs qui organise
sa qui participent à la réussite de
l'événement également la mairie de saint
cyr qui nous met à disposition gymnase
sans eux on pourrait pas faire tout ce
tournoi donc je les remercie vivement
et merci à vous également élevé sage
effacés encore un tout petit mot de
sport ce qu'il y aura également du tir à
l'arc ce week-end c'est le concours
salle 2 x 18 m de guyancourt avec des
duels il est programmé ce samedi et
dimanche au gymnase maurice baquet un
rendez-vous sélective pour le
championnat de france
au programme des airs classiques d arc à
poulies et sans visa 26 cible au départ
les finales seront à partir de 14h le
dimanche c'est aussi noël en ce moment
les marchés de noël continue sur saint
quentin en yvelines ont fait un petit
tour d'horizon à la
hier le marché se veut solidaire rendez
vous à l'hôtel de ville de 13h30 à 19h
pour villepreux plus de 20 exposants
vous attendent sur la place jacques
riboud des ateliers créatifs seront
notamment proposés par la municipalité
le centre alfred de vigny et la ville de
voisins-le-bretonneux proposent leur 36e
marché de noël 89 exposants vous feront
découvrir leurs spécialités à maurepas
les festivités débutent dès le vendredi
13 décembre
au programme marché coral et spectacles
de patineurs professionnels
il est maintenant temps d'ouvrir notre
calendrier de l'avent jusqu'au 19
décembre tv77 vous propose des idées
cadeaux décoration ou encore des idées
sorties
regardons ce qui se cache derrière ce
jeudi 12 décembre alors voilà tout à
fait typique du togo fabriqué en mai ben
les bennes est un bois qui pousse très
lentement et qui est très dur et donc
les sculptures sont difficiles une
sculpture canine carrare elizabeth au
lion proposeront à la vente ce week end
ses deux saint quentinois sont bénévoles
à avenir togo une association créée en
1995 par une pasteure manai et vous
soutenir l'action du cast du centre
d'action sociale ou togo qui accueille
des enfants abandonnés handicap etc
terrain c'est de les loger de les
nourrir de veiller à leur santé de
scolariser quand ils grandissent et de
les accompagner jusqu'à ce qu'ils aient
un métier entre les manquements à qui ce
qu'ils aient acquis leur indépendance à
venir togo est l'une des trois
associations présentes elle sera au
marché solidaire de saint quentin en
yvelines avec amnesty international et
artisans du monde
les 14 et 15 décembre prochains la
commanderie propose un temps fort lors
de son noël décalé il faut penser aux
autres parce que c'est peut-être notre
côté décalé où on a envie de pas être
forcément être dans la surconsommation
dans les déchets on veut être
responsable en fait solidaire un marché
solidaire complété par un marché de
créateurs saint quentinois grâce auquel
le pied du sapin devrait se trouver bien
garni un rendez vous pour les amoureux
des livres les bibliothèques
versaillaise proposent leurs opérations
de désherbage des ouvrages ce samedi 14
décembre le public pourra ainsi acheter
des livres en double dans les
bibliothèques à des prix attractifs
c'est le moment de notre virgule cinéma
cette semaine on retrouve lui pocan le
directeur du ciné cet élan cours pour
les côtes dans les salles aussi décès de
cette semaine le très joli deuxième film
deuxième jeu précise de nicolas bedos
après le très réussi et remarquable
monsieur label made que vous avez
certainement vu avec nicolas bedos et
doria thiviers dans cette fois ci un
casting exceptionnel
daniel auteuil qui fort heureusement est
très bien employé dans ce film et c'est
vrai que tu ailles un petit peu de mal à
trouver des rôles à sa mesure
hu à sa démesure c'est quand même très
grand acteur il faut pas que je dis bien
sûr la très grand de fanny ardant il ya
aussi pierre arditi puis un caennais et
doriath il y est bien sûr la muse la
femme
l'amoureuse une collabo fouad c'est un
film une comédie dramatique tendre et
féroce à la fois je vais pas vous
raconter l'histoire par le menu
mais le scénario est très original on
propose à daniel auteuil de revivre de
plus belle journée de sa vie grâce à une
société qu'inventer guillaume canet pas
plus vous venez de découvrir dans nos
salles il est encore à l'affiché cette
semaine au ciné cette un très joli film
pour cette fin d'année
[Musique]
un petit détour hors des frontières des
yvelines cette semaine nos confrères
devient grand paris vous font découvrir
l'art urbain
après une tournée mondiale les 360 all
star débarque à paris sur seine des
artistes internationaux regardez c'est
un show qui va vous en mettre plein les
yeux et les oreilles les 360 all stars
sont entrés la rue dans les salles de
spectacle le casting est de renommée
internationale cet artiste chacun au
sommet de son art composent l'équipe un
double champion du monde de bmx de break
dancer un freestyler de basket-ball un
record man du monde de cette grande roue
et de musiciens qui accompagnent
héritent leurs incroyables performances
les 360 all stars sont en quelque sorte
mais circadien des temps modernes
ce spectacle c'est un circuit urbain
ça signifie que l'on remplace les arts
traditionnels très stéréotypé part de
l'art de rue contemporain les acrobates
deviennent des champion de breakdance le
traditionnel jongleur un basketteur
freestyle et nous ne faisons pas de
monocycle mais du bmx
en gros tout ce qui est traditionnel on
transforme en arts de rue
je pense que c'est un très bon spectacle
parce que tout ce qu'on y fait et très
bien fait comme et donc nos performances
et c'est très beau c'est drôle il ya
beaucoup d'acrobaties donc si vous
n'êtes pas ici c'est que vous êtes en
des endroits inédits en france le
spectacle est moderne et original car
l'idée est de plaire un jeune public
avec des disciplines dans l'air du temps
très différentes les unes des autres
il faut cependant une organisation
particulière aux 360 all star pour
harmoniser le show je vois que la clé
c'est trouver un terrain d'entente entre
nos différentes disciplines
pour nous la solution c'est la rotation
chacun son tour
c'est pour ça que ça s'appelle 360 all
star pour le côté 362 grecque
le basket-ball est suivi du bmx qui est
suivi du breakdance et c'est la musique
qui fait le lien entre tout ça venez
admirer les 360 all-stars au xiiie a
jusqu'au 31 décembre
c'est la fin de ce statut de loisirs
merci nous avoir suivi on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]